[Music]
George Clooney is in the film and you
actually have a scene with George yeah
scenes with George Clooney and those are
very funny were you comfortable I mean
you're a young guy and then there's
George Clooney right and you're going to
shoot with him that must be intimidating
yeah it's a little it's a little like
you kind of when you first meet him you
can't believe you know you've seen this
face in magazines and everything and
it's like wow there is yeah kind of what
you're experiencing now actually what
whispered as you seem bright you seem
pretty calm yeah anyway so so you meet
so you see George Clooney and what's
with you first do a scene with him well
we got in the car and then he kind of
turned to me and very loudly said so
which Coen do you like more and I sort
of when he knows you're wearing a
microphone yeah exactly and then and
then as things went on like the other
day we were doing press and I kept
getting asked like did he prank you
because he's famous for these very
famous for pranks and then I I kind of
said to him like you didn't prank
anybody was like yeah I don't know I'm
kind of over the pranks yes and then
we're on the red carpet and Pam and Josh
and all the other Josh Brolin all the
other actors in the film have been so
inclusive of me and so I'm just warm and
everything and then we're on the red
carpet and we're all taking a photo
together and I'm kind of like oh my god
I can't believe I'm taking a photo all
these people and George says okay let's
all turn around and face our backs to
the camera like that and that'll be
funny that'll be funny I'm like oh I
guess that's what people do on a red
carpet and we did it and then and then
later I was sent a picture of what
really had it yeah and so he
right you guys just look like dicks yeah
we just look like this yeah so that's
yeah yeah hey thanks for watching please
subscribe to my youtube channel so they
will stop making me shoot these videos
please